[Musique]
bref juste je vais juste dire bravo mme
aux lillois l'équipe de lille parce que
franchement c'est une conçoit supporters
de lille ou pas c'est un exploit
exceptionnel
mon rêve est en toi je comprends ta joie
on a fêté ça tu imagines genesis cadeau
pour moi que j'ai hésité à tram n'est
les sharks d'hier soir bah ouais mais
chante un peu le fumigène attaque les
couleurs de la france
ça ne l'intéresse pas salut cyril 400000
gilet jaune dans la rue on n'a jamais eu
le privilège d'être reçu par le
président grand n'importe quoi ils
oublient ce qu'il a fait ils oublient ce
qu'il a fait aux jeunes pendant un an
j'en peux plus d'abord je pense que si
c'est bien joué sur le sur la forme sur
la technique de qom et c'est parce que
c'est en fait le truc emmanuel macron
seca manuel macro on le met en top gun
avec des rafales ça marche on le met
avec thomas pesquet dans la navette
spatiale ça marche
non mais là c'est qui c'est qui ces
micro ne m'a lu une manuelle et aux fins
c'est un you were ça ne va pas et en
plus il l'a fait s qualité de président
de la république dans la maison de tous
les français quels elysées c'est le
mélange des genres qui ne va pas que
macro lui-même le fasse c'est très bien
qu'ils soient sains pas très bien mais
hollande était sympa de gaulle était pas
très sympa est ce qu'on demande à un
président de la république d'être sympa
est ce que les salons je crois pas
d'emploi alors bien alors qu'on avait
l'organiser et l'année prochaine on
espère je le dis aux téléspectateurs je
vais vous dire ce que 10 mars à ce que
dit les sionistes des patrons de
constellé avant de partir ils vous
disent la plus grosse tuile qui pourrait
nous arriver c'est de gagner la
meilleure chose ça peut nous arriver
c'est de finir dans les cinq premiers
deuxième ça serait la meilleure place
donc là c'est vrai que c'est
exceptionnel on deuxième c'est la
meilleure glacis pourquoi parce que si
vous êtes premier vous devez organiser
l'année prochaine et l'année d'après je
vous dire ça coûte 30 bar cette affaire
oui on organise l'eurovision junior et
on espère qu'on dormait l'eurovision
junior
aussi je fais d'aller que dans
tu as quand même jean marie je vous aime
beaucoup que l'étoile jaune c'était d'un
très mode et pouvoir c'est à dire que à
l'époque c'est ce que hitler avait
trouvé pour repérer immédiatement les
jeux xbla
on a on a quand même le bout des pages
et le ministre de la santé qui nous dit
les personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés
seront défavorisées
là c'est la dictature faut maintenant
arrêter à des morts à la fin oui c'est
sûr que là l'art de la comparer aux
ailes avant tout content moi je suis
totalement contre le pass annie terre on
va diviser les frères c'est bravo à des
bons et des mauvais citoyens ben moi je
suis un mauvais citoyen ait si on me
gêne du cinéma parce que je l'est pas
ben je rentrerai par derrière comme si
on m'empêche de mainfonds restaurant va
ces résultats on va vous reconnaitre moi
j'irai je ne veux pas de ce pass annie
terre il ya une seule catégorie de
français
il ya des gens qui veulent se faire
vacciner qui peuvent pas encore donc je
dis non pas s'étaler browner a pas sauf
que le prêt on va rediffuser ce robot
est ce que tu prêt s'il vous plaît
j'aimerais que tout le monde sorte de
l'arrivée qu'on laisse franck seule
sortez tous ces jeunes en peine la régie
merci sorte
[Applaudissements]
manger du code barre et je vous remercie
très certainement la fontaine diffusion
je changerais de numéro celui tu sais
moi j'avais dit non ça ne me rends
compte aimes-tu c'est moche et rires
j'ai trois choses à dire à d'abord les
assassins ce ton ce sont eux les
assassins ceux qui depuis un an et demi
nous [ __ ] des prisons joue avec nos
nerfs joue avec nous juhasz nos enfants
qui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui veulent faire vacciner nos
enfants qui aujourd'hui nous fout des
masques à longueur de journée qui
aujourd'hui nous emprisonnent qui
aujourd'hui nous empêche de vivre et
anti aujourd'hui nous empêche de voir
nos grands parents c'est aujourd'hui
nous empêche de vivre notre propre ville
sharon est dans une dictature
aujourd'hui
d'accord j'étais présentateur sur la
chaîne hbo les gt présentateur et vous
le savez sur france télévisions je
prendrai le soir 3 j'ai toujours été
super bien noté personnel tandis que je
délirais dommage mais c'est vrai
l'exploit oyo code il se permet de dire
cette espèce de crétin en face de moi
non mais il avait à dire qui c'est cette
femme c'est la généticienne numéro un
qui est aussi un erreur vrai si tous ces
mares f1 mais c'est scandaleux ce que
vous faites vous êtes de complotiste de
conspirationnistes d'abord un
journaliste il doit douter de ce que des
gouvernements vous êtes obligés de nous
traiter blache et on vous dira tu as un
truc me demandez si vous voulez on lui a
demandé s'il voulait faire vacciner ses
enfants il a dit non j'ai vu ça juste
avant de venir à un moment comment ça se
passe entre ses avocats et ceux
coupables voilà est-ce qu'un moment il
vous ils font l'art me bounni voilà
c'est moi comment ça se passe quelle est
votre relation avec lui parce que et
quand il se passe un peu que même comme
dans beaucoup de métiers on sent les
choses vous sentez les choses si on
appelait tout je pense qu'on est là
avait a toujours d'ailleurs une approche
très vous disiez contre vous disiez
c'est lui on sait que c'est lui mais
vain mot et tout que ni le nom au départ
en fait si on voulait avant que
johnattan soient interpellés et placés
en garde à vue
il y avait une fuite il y avait en fait
à un article ou une presse locale cet
article il est pas sorti pour rien
monsieur d'aval c'est qu'à un moment et
à peut-être pas se passer quelque chose
il sort de notre cabinet et on se
regarde on dit c'est pas lui non oui on
s'en est voulu d'avoir pensé un instant
que c'était lui est ce que parce que il
faut le connaître un nounou on approche
fou ce que vous dites mais vous savez
c'est pas parce que c'est celui qu'on à
ostraciser qu'on a montré du doigt en en
le traitant de monstres qu'on a consumé
nous on ne le juge pas nous sommes ses
avocats on essaye d'avoir une paix
sociale en ce moment dans une france qui
est très vive
et je veux ça c'est bien de le dire mais
oui c'est bien ce que je peux répondre à
les irrite paulo après je voudrais
écouter monsieur ben ça alors allez-y
thierry congard motion avec aujourd'hui
jean marie bigard est un homme très
sympathique
oui mais ça c'est pas le débat dans
l'histoire toutes les grandes maladies
ont été éradiqués par des vaccins
ford faut le choléra n'a pas été le cas
[Applaudissements]
le dj supportable même chose chez vous
c'était ce matin on s'est appelé on
s'est dit c'est bizarre ça n'a pas futé
est là cet après midi s'affûter puisque
christophe réa vous avez appelé par tous
ben non moi je sais pas moi j'aurais
préféré le dire moi tu vois
bah ouais vous déçu qu'est ce que
voulait dire je vais dire que voilà que
tu es habite à la maison pas plus de
deux semaines vous est pas peu de gens
ont des bons joueurs on verra d'abord ce
que des bisous puis on verra après
exactement christophe qui va animer à
prendre ou à laisser à partir de lundi
je finissais des premiers lundi je suis
très content alors christophe lapone ya
plein de gens qui nous disent voilà
c'est j'aime bien jouer ou pas ah bah
non
le jeu ça preneur parce que tu t'y en
fait tu mens et on rencontre que je vais
me faire 25 nouveaux copains ouais c'est
ça 24 peut-être est un ennemi le
banquier à ça j'ai hâte de la voir en
ligne ensuite la semaine prochaine
quatre émissions encore la folie ensuite
quatre émissions encore ensuite tout ça
ça dégage christophe dechavanne à
prendre ou à laisser montiel fera le 6 à
7 en direct avec tout le thé les 100
meilleures séquences de lundi je vous
raconte un petit peu tout seul au bar
d'origine droit on invite jean messia
dans l'ensemble des plateaux télé de
france et de navarre il pas sauvé la vie
dans les vtc
d'ailleurs je zappe sur les scènes je
tombe sur ces news hier j'en ai c'est
qu'elle passe à sonia l'argent qu'il est
là j'ai vu dans un cube il n'y a rien à
granby ce que tu as trop forcé sur ton
coeur à cause du vélo
non je crois que c'est j'ai trop forcé
par le stress
vraiment ah ouais ouais pas les stresser
de quoi bein 57 ans de télé ça fait
beaucoup 53 merz avait sur les plus durs
mais c'est beaucoup de stress
c'est vrai vraiment et je me suis mis
une grosse grosse pression au cours des
dernières années
en voulant réaliser un challenge dont je
rêvais et toi aussi d'aller sur scène
une opération comme la mienne a été
gigantesque il fallait convention genval
qu'en face afrique le portage comme des
bouche la jambe qu'on surveille de début
d'avc dans la vidéo on saura si vous
avez des séquelles uniquement au réveil
on opère un choeur par le cerveau donc
on sera au réveil est donc le protocole
c'est ça le l'anesthésique 01 10 voilà
si ça se passe mal on prévient qui si ça
veut dire quoi
non mais vous savez nous allons prendre
un gros risque avec cette opération il y
avait 50 50
tant que qui on prévient mais si vous
prenez ma femme d'abord mais vous
débranchez mais quand ça veut dire vous
débranchez michel s'est engueulé plein
de gens de ce métier à cause de ou oui
vous savez ça ou par michel tu dois en
parler oui bien sûr qu'est ce que j'ai
pu manquer la cause lui invente comment
tu peux supporter ce mec est comment tu
peux hanouna écoute franchement mais il
haïra il frappa trois mois gilles va
faire 20 ans dans la jet d'affairé 11,4
et à chaque fois je me bats ta maison
vous rendez pas compte
vous rendez pas compte que c'est que
faire des directs ou les soins que vous
l'aimez vous l'aimez pas c'est un autre
problème qui soit clivant hop
actuellement c'est pas le problème lui
de chavannes nous quand on a fait lui
adrien les gens nîmes vous n'imaginez
pas ce que c'est que faire une
quotidienne en direct tous les soirs qui
se termine à 20h 20h15 20h30 22h23 enfin
syrie ni fait de planter
les gens se rendent pas compte que c'est
comme il faut
on